amis téléspectateurs bonjour vous
regardez et maintenant l'émission qui
revient toujours avec plaisir et
toujours avec vous sur l'actualité
politique de la semaine vous connaissez
le principe hashtag et maintenant si
vous souhaitez réagir aujourd'hui avec
moi sur ce plateau des invités trier sur
le volet ils ont là et la manière ils
sont très intelligents et n'ont pas peur
du débat l'incomparable George Marc
Benhamou et la bonjour George Marc ça va
vous êtes écrivain et producteur je
signale que deux de vos derniers
documentaires ont été sélectionnés
lauréat de l'audiovisuel il s'agit
d'Hitler Staline le choc des tyrans et
c'était l'Algérie la guerre d'Algérie
c'était la guerre d'Algérie écrit avec
l'historien Benjamin Stora Chloé ridle
bonjour directrice adjointe de
l'Institut Rousseau vous avez écrit
d'une guerre à l'autre aux éditions de
l'eau merci d'être avec nous on
accueille aussi Charles Consigny bonjour
c'est une première pour vous avocat à
essayer cette bienvenue et Rachel Kahn
écrivain et juriste vous publiez les
grandes et les petites choses c'est une
bande dessinée qui revient sur votre
étonnant parcours c'est à retrouver aux
éditions Nathan merci d'être là dans
cette émission on se demandera si
l'avenir de la planète dépend d'une taxe
sur les plus riches si l'avenir de la
droite est dépend d'un vote sur l'IVG on
s'interrogera sur le plan du
gouvernement en matière de lutte contre
le racisme et sur son programme en
matière d'immigration tiens encore une
loi est-ce que celle-ci sera la bonne on
verra ça dans le détail mais d'abord
merci président Larcher le bras de fer
continue autour de la réforme des
retraites ce lundi les députés
commenceront l'examen du texte dans
l'hémicycle mais le gouvernement n'en
démord pas l'âge de départ à la retraite
sera repoussée à 64 ans ça n'est pas
négociable cette semaine pourtant près
de 1 million 300000 personnes ont
manifesté dans toute la France et plus
que lors de la précédente mobilisation
et pour les syndicats non plus bah les
64 ans ne sont pas négociables écoutez
si les élus du peuple n'écoutent pas le
peuple le peuple va continuer à se
détourner de ceux qui sont censés les
représenter avec le risque et bien qu'il
y a encore plus
de députés d'extrême droite au Parlement
et ça sera pas les syndicats qui seront
responsables de ça j'ose dire
qu'aujourd'hui 31 janvier 2023 on a une
des plus grandes manifestations qui
soient organisées dans notre pays depuis
des dizaines d'années et bien il faut
que le gouvernement entendent parce
qu'autrement on ira vers un problème
démocratique genre je marque est-ce
qu'on est en face d'un problème
démocratique comme ça on est dans une
impasse actuellement oui visiblement on
sait maintenant qu'il y a une sorte de
compte à rebours avec le fameux article
41 qu'on découvre
et on découvre le 47 avec ce compte à
rebours faut 50 jours etc donc qui va
perdre cette bataille au temps politique
de l'opinion est-ce que c'est le
gouvernement est-ce que ce sont ceux qui
déposent les 20 000 amendements mais il
y a quelque chose qui est un peu
inquiétant du point de vue du
gouvernement c'est vrai que il y a deux
clignotants c'est est-ce que la droite
et les républicains vont tenir est-ce
que le groupe des dissidents de Monsieur
Pradier qui veulent être plus sociaux
que que sociaux vont et cette réforme et
est-ce que l'aile gauche nous ce qu'il
en reste ou ce qu'on appelle l'aile
gauche de la macronie va voter ce que
Madame pompille et quelques autres qui
ont des états d'amour donc il y a un
suspense politique et il y a un deuxième
suspense qui est un suspense sociétal
moi j'ai l'impression que le pays se
cadre je suis assez favorable à la
retraite je suis favorable
au gouvernement et je pense que cette
réforme elle est pas elle est
elle est bizarrement pas bouclée pas
très bien bouclé on voit les défauts les
problèmes sur les femmes les carrières
l'ombre donc il y a un et ça veut dire
une chose et j'y repense et c'est
quelques conversations de la fin de vie
avec François Mitterrand j'en suis venu
après l'avoir été un peu oubliée à
penser que profondément la retraite à 60
ans et comme les congés payés en acquis
quasiment immuables alors qu'on le
déplace à 62 ans mais là il y a une
sorte de blocage sociologique les gens
se sont appropriés cette retraite autour
de 60 ans et en tout cas pour les gens
de peine comme on disait siècle c'est un
peu difficile d'admettre qu'on puisse
travailler très tard
dans un moment où c'est quoi c'est le
premier qui va craquer c'est ça entre le
gouvernement et la rue on est vraiment
dans un affrontement à ce niveau-là
effectivement c'est l'impression que ça
donne mais moi je me questionne
profondément sur la stratégie qui est
celle du gouvernement parce que plus ils
disent que ça n'est pas négociable et
que de toute façon il ne céderont pas
plus l'opposition ça croit dans la
société et on a effectivement
l'impression une réforme moi que je
trouve très injuste sur le fond parce
qu'ils ont toujours pas réglé une
question fondamentale qui est celle du
sort qui serait réservée aux personnes
qui commencent à travailler à 19 20 ans
et qui cotiserait 44 ans voire 45 ans
plutôt que les 43 ans classique donc ça
ils ne répondent toujours pas à cette
injustice alors que ça fait quand même
maintenant plusieurs mois qu'on en
discute ils disent qu'ils sont ouverts à
la prise en compte de critères de
pénibilité mais on apprend avant-hier
que en fait le port de charge lourdes
qui concerne notamment les déménageurs
n'est pas considéré comme quelque chose
de pénible donc à chaque fois qu'ils
disent qu'on peut négocier sur quelque
chose on a l'impression que c'est quand
même tout ça est très improvisé etc et
puis sur la méthode
ils n'ont pas actuellement de majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a des gens
dans la majorité relative qui s'opposent
cette réforme et donc il est question
soit de recourir aux 49-3 soit de
recourir à l'article 47 ans la
Constitution qui permettrait au
gouvernement de légiférer par ordonnance
si l'Assemblée nationale le Parlement
met trop de temps à examiner
le texte mais pour utiliser cet article
il faut qu'il y ait un critère d'urgence
qui soit vérifié qui se vérifie dans le
cadre d'acceptation et donc ça je pense
pas que ça passera devant le conseil et
puis ce serait quand même un affront
terrible vous avez quand même des
millions de gens dans la rue qui perdent
qui se mettent en grève qui perdent des
gens on est au milieu de légitimité
Charles vous avez beaucoup de gens dans
la rue et puis la légitimité du
Parlement avec un texte qui va arriver
lundi dans l'hémicycle comment on sort
de ce conflit qui semble pour l'instant
aujourd'hui insoluble moi je pensais à
dépendre de deux choses d'abord ce que
vont faire les députés les républicains
est-ce qu'ils vont ou pas voter ce texte
selon ce qu'ils vont obtenir du
gouvernement c'est d'ailleurs un peu
étonnant et instructif que ce soit les
députés LR qui soit en train d'amander
dans un sens plus social un texte sur
les retraites c'est quand même inattendu
que que les macronistes soient encore
plus à droite que les répu mais c'est ce
qui est en train de se passer donc je
moi si je peux faire une prédiction je
pense que ils vont obtenir un certain
nombre de choses que le gouvernement va
leur lâcher de manière très très joyeux
et volontaire et qui va permettre qui
vote ce texte et cette contestation
c'est un drap tout seul avec le vote du
texte moi je pense que c'est ça juste ce
que vous dites c'est que là on parle
beaucoup du Parlement mais à partir du
moment où cette réforme sera votée vous
pariez que et bah la contestation
s'éteindra moi c'est mon pari après je
je savais pas forcément mon souhait je
en l'occurrence je m'en fiche un peu de
cette réforme des retraites pour être
clair je pense que de toute façon le
régime est mort et que plus personne ne
compte sérieusement sur le régime de
répartition sur les caisses de l'État
oui enfin on cotise des sommes
considérables pour des retraites qui
sont de plus en plus hypothétiques donc
bon mais mais par ailleurs je pense que
la contestation a dans les mains quelque
chose un espèce de brasier qui qui la
réforme qui a pris feu et c'est à eux
aussi de savoir le transformer
j'entendais Martinez les autres
responsables syndicaux les oppositions
je pense qu'ils ont là quelque chose qui
peut qui peut prendre forme et qui peut
bloquer l'action gouvernementale mais
c'est à eux de s'en saisir je sais pas
s'ils sont suffisamment déterminés pour
le faire parce que malgré tout les
retraites c'est quand même pas un sujet
galvanisant bah on va quand même qu'il y
a des millions de personnes dans la rue
Michel comment le gouvernement le
Parlement peut prendre en compte cette
colère aujourd'hui alors il y a les
amendements on parle de 20000
amendements qui ont été déposés comment
finalement trouver un compromis
là-dessus entre la rue et le Parlement
ce qui m'attriste en fait c'est que sur
le fond de de sur le fond des retraites
et sur la technicité en fait de cette
loi c'est qu'on en parle au finalement
très peu j'ai plus le sentiment que les
syndicats monsieur
Martinez en première ligne et l'extrême
gauche de toute façon prends ce projet
de loi comme parce que depuis le mois de
juin il y a un monsieur qui veut être
Premier ministre qu'il l'est pas et en
fait tout est bon
et que depuis le début de toute façon
depuis le début de cette mandature c'est
des débats sans fin une obstruction des
séances et mon grand regret c'est
effectivement que le Parlement que le
travail parlementaire ne puisse pas se
faire justement sur des sujets précis de
fonds
de blocage normalement je sais pas nous
représente qui sont déposés sont des
amendements de fonds
le Parlement normalement nous
représentants sont normalement des
citoyens éclairés on a vu les débats
depuis le début de la mandature en tout
cas ce qui est ce qu'on peut reprocher
quand même si on est partisans de la
nécessité d'une réforme parce
qu'effectivement ça tient plus ça craque
ça tient plus c'est quand même que
regarde de l'ambition initiale du
macronisme qui était fait finalement de
rocardise c'est-à-dire cette
consultation bas vers le haut
de cette dimension CFDT finalement du
social rien est au rendez-vous on est
passé de cette ambition là social
libérale
et justement à une sorte de verticalité
qui fait que la loi tombe oui dans une
concertation donc ça c'est pas si elle a
eu lieu vraiment et puis il y a eu
quelques concertations quand même il y a
eu des discussions il y a eu des années
de concertation moi j'y comprends plus
rien très honnêtement depuis la première
réforme systémique jusqu'à aujourd'hui
je sais je ne mesure pas le niveau de de
concertation je n'y comprends plus rien
je pense que beaucoup de gens sont
perdues
très bien le truc c'est que moi je suis
attachée justement à cette mutation de
la société je partage votre position
c'est ce système là ne tient plus
réellement mais par ailleurs si on est
dans l'évolution de la société si on est
sur les générations futures il faudra
bien une proposition de loi qui prennent
en compte leur allongement de la vie
donc je n'arrive pas à comprendre cette
dichotomie entre
notamment les écologistes
j'ai le sentiment que sur les enjeux
notamment de développement durable qui
est une conjugaison entre le pilier
économique social et environnemental et
les yeux rivés sur les générations
futures que j'ai pas entendu moi
beaucoup de personnes qui sont dans la
rue nous parler des générations alors on
va attendre Elizabeth borne justement
qui a rappelé ce jeudi dans l'émission
l'événement sur France 2 bien la
nécessité selon elle de cette réforme
écoutez là
c'est un effort et je mesure ce que ça
représente pour beaucoup de Français
mais ma responsabilité c'est aussi de
dire la vérité aux Français de dire que
si on ne fait pas cette réforme des
retraites c'est notre système par
répartition qui ne tiendra pas tu vois
il y a un défaut de pédagogie on entend
beaucoup ce mot en ce moment de
pédagogie de la réforme non c'est
simplement que le gouvernement assume
des choix qui consiste à faire payer aux
travailleurs le rééquilibrage du système
de répartition et n'explore pas d'autres
pistes qui serait possible pour
l'équilibrer ce système de répartition
on pourrait penser par exemple à les
dividendes par exemple les
les cotisations sur les très haut
retenues sont capés
plafonnées on pourrait faire sauter le
plafond on pourrait aussi décider de
mieux taxer les patrimoines on pourrait
décider d'imposer des cotisations sur
les robots alors c'était une proposition
qui avait beaucoup fait rire à l'époque
où Benoît Hamon était candidat à
l'élection présidentielle mais de fait
il y a une robotisation une numérisation
de l'économie française qui ont détruit
des emplois sans sans payer des
cotisations
de pédagogie c'est une question de
rapport de force et à chaque fois sous
couvert de dire on n'a pas fait assez de
pédagogie en fait il masque le fait
qu'ils font des choix politiques et il
balayent d'un revers de la main en
disant non mais toute façon nous on veut
pas augmenter les impôts nous on veut
pas appauvrir les les retraités mais on
ne parle pas par exemple des traits
grosses retraites il y a eu un article
dans Libération hier qui est sorti sur
la retraite que touche notamment les
anciens chefs d'État Nicolas Sarkozy qui
touche entre 2013 et 2019 680000 euros
de retraite que nous on paye quoi
ça compte symboliquement en fait le
problème c'est quand vous voulez faire
payer plus des gens qui commencent à
travailler à 19 20 ans c'est à dire quoi
les premiers cordées les gens qui sont
des aidants les gens qui sont des
chauffeurs
qui sont des je sais pas
s'il y a il y a un truc là qui ne passe
pas et qui ne peut pas être compris
Charles sur cette histoire de pédagogie
pour vous le problème aujourd'hui le
l'impasse dans laquelle on est c'est un
manque de pédagogie de la part de
gouvernement c'est ça la raison pour moi
c'est un manque de justice pour moi le
problème des macronistes c'est que ils
n'ont pas donné à aucun moment de se de
ce double quinquennat
pas encore terminé malheureusement mais
mais ils n'ont pas ils n'ont pas donné à
aucun moment le moindre la moindre
réforme de justice le moindre signe de
justice c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont une
justice moi je trouve que moi j'observe
qu'ils ont gouverné de manière
absolument systématique quel que soit
les décisions qu'ils aient prises dans
le sens de la préservation des intérêts
des Français déjà des plus fortunés et
jamais dans le sens de des pauvres et je
considère moi que le pouvoir politique
il doit être du côté des pauvres il doit
pas être du côté des riches les riches
n'ont pas besoin non mais étonné
si vous voulez
je sais pas c'est pas du tout être
socialiste que dire ça c'est que moi je
suis pour le libéralisme etc mais je
suis pour aussi les correctifs du
libéralisme par exemple
quand on est libéral on est pour la
concurrence libre et non faussée on est
contre les monopoles et pour ça il faut
bien une autorité de régulation qui s'en
occupe je considère que quand on que le
rôle du président de la République du
gouvernement c'est d'être du côté des
gens qui ont besoin de lui qui ont
besoin de c'est pas vrai de dire que les
grands patrons français les grands
groupes français les grandes fortunes
françaises et même la bourgeoisie plus
plus qu'on qu'on voit sur Instagram
faire du ski en ce moment ont besoin
d'avoir de leur côté Emmanuel Macron
Élisabeth borne les différents ministres
ça n'est pas vrai ils n'ont pas besoin
de et je considère que le péché du
macronisme c'est d'avoir
systématiquement gouverner pour ces
gens-là en donnant le sentiment à mon
avis qui n'est pas complètement un
sentiment d'écraser ou de laisser
écraser les les classes les plus
défavorisées on a plein de problèmes en
France de ce côté-là on sait qu'on a des
salaires qui sont très faibles par
exemple dans beaucoup d'entreprises
qu'est-ce qui a été fait pour que ces
salaires soient augmenter à mon sens
rien ou à peu près rien et donc c'est
difficile dans cette situation là de
demander aux gens de faire des efforts
quand vous avez le sentiment quand vous
donnez le sentiment que vous n'êtes pas
de leur côté merci Charles
à une crise politique se dirige vers une
crise politique aujourd'hui
je sais pas mais en tout cas pour Chris
politique ou pédagogique moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est une affaire mal
en mancher cette histoire de retraite
qui est beaucoup plus fondamentale
entrepôt logique que qu'on dit quoi on
sort une réforme qui devait être
systémique cassé la baraque on nous
resserre une réforme qui doit au mois de
septembre selon les dires du président
servir à combler à permettre de faire du
développement de financer la transition
écologique et puis on nous explique de
moins plus tard qu'en fait c'est pour
équilibrer les comptes en fait donc
c'est mal emmanché ce dialogue là j'ai
entendu Gilbert le dire je suis assez
d'accord avec lui un grand président
comme Mitterrand il aurait fait les yeux
dans les yeux avec les Français
expliquer la nécessité la justice ces
deux critères ce dialogue entre le
président et le peuple or ce dialogue
avec a pas été a pas été fait il y a pas
il y a pas de lien une sorte de
verticalité la prise de relais l'autre
jeudi par Madame borne de ce discours
qui passe pas qui est contredit par
Monsieur le Maire par Monsieur Darmanin
c'est un brouillard alors que le
dialogue entre le souverain et le peuple
aurait dû se faire il se fait pas et aux
forces de l'esprit absolument et en plus
c'est un style le tout dans le peuple
que finalement cette réforme est
peut-être pas nécessaire et qu'elle va
servir le bon plaisir du du souverain et
là le doute ainsi ça qui peut être un
ferment insurrectionnel en tout cas de
de refus de cette réforme facilement
a-t-il enfin pris la mesure du problème
d'un autre problème cette semaine il a
en tout cas dévoilé son plan pour lutter
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme 80
mesures pour ce que la première ministre
considère comme une nouvelle étape dans
le bas pour la qualité des chances
écoutez là il est intolérable que des
personnes puissent encore être mis au
banc blessé et parfois même tuer en
raison de ce qu'elles sont en raison de
leur foi le gouvernement est pleinement
mobilisé contre le racisme
l'antisémitisme et les discriminations
c'est un combat qui nous rassemble un
combat qui nous guide c'est agir pour
l'égalité des chances agir pour défendre
la République et les valeurs de la
France le combat contre la haine
continue et continuera jusqu'au bout
nous sommes déterminés chaque année plus
d'un million de personnes subissent une
discrimination ou une atteinte à
caractère raciste ou antisémite en
France sont des chiffres du gouvernement
Rachel est-ce que le gouvernement
précisément a enfin pris la mesure du
problème avec ce plan
déjà on va voir après moi je suis pas
certaine qu'un plan et que ces annonces
que l'on connaît c'est-à-dire que sur le
papier on sait qu'on doit lutter contre
toutes les formes d'intolérance
d'ailleurs c'est pas simplement
l'antisémitisme le racisme moi ce qui
m'interroge beaucoup ce sont plutôt
alors deux points d'abord la citoyenneté
parce que moi je suis attaché à ça et je
pense que le travail de fond pour lutter
justement contre le racisme
antisémitisme et autres ça commence par
la citoyenneté est très tôt pas
simplement en faisant des ateliers dans
les lycées à la maternelle sur ce qui
est notre universalisme notre humanisme
à la française
en précisant aussi aux enfants que de
toute façon
lorsqu'on est lorsqu'on commet ce genre
d'actes voilà c'est c'est un délice du
pénal voilà mais par ailleurs
j'interroge des associations qui à mon
sens notamment SOS racistes qui à mon
sens on fait du mal à notre société
pourquoi parce que déjà la manière ces
derniers temps cette manière de lutter
contre le racisme en scindant la société
en fracturant la société en pointant du
doigt les uns et les autres avec une
forme de victimmocratie ne fait pas du
bien à la mise en place de l'égalité
réelle on va voir on va voir les mesures
prévues par par le gouvernement avec ce
plan 2023 2026 ce plan qui prévoit une
visite mémorielle obligatoire pour
chaque élève la formation des agents
publics ou encore du testing le testing
des discriminations à l'embauche
systématisée dans les entreprises
Georges Marc même question est-ce que
voilà on y est enfin on va vraiment on a
vraiment pris la mesure du problème
aujourd'hui écoutez on peut se féliciter
que le gouvernement fasse des évidences
c'est évident qu'il faut lutter contre
le racisme l'antisémitisme etc mais on
l'a pas fait
par exemple sur SOS raciste je trouve
Rachel un peu sévère SOS Racisme a eu
plusieurs époques et concrètement si
aujourd'hui on fait du testing c'est
grâce à SOS Racisme qui a imposé cette
technique alors on peut discuter deux
candidatures d'emploi à une difficulté
de certaines de leurs positions mais
globalement le le bilan et globalement
positif comment il dit mais après ils
ont installé quand même ces réflexes
alors on peut discuter non il faut que
ça vienne des profondeurs et il faut que
ça vienne des profondeurs du pays
effectivement la question de la
citoyenneté à tous les étages et
fondamental mais on peut aussi
s'intéresser à aux grandes déclarations
des politiques sur l'antiémitisme le
racisme et les mettre en regard de
certaines décisions de justice je parle
sur le contrôle de notre avocat ici
présent de déni absolu dans la faire
sarahimie qui est à Hur c'est à dire que
bien sûr que le président va faire de
grandes déclarations mais sur le terrain
concrètement des juges etc ou à d'autres
niveaux ça se traduit pas un plan
exactement le même plan en 2018 enfin
pas exactement le même plan mais un plan
présenté par le par Edward Philippe pour
les années 2018-2020 contre le racisme
et l'antisémitisme ça a donné quoi ça
rien donné on n'a pas avancé en 5 ans
encore heureux que la justice soit
indépendant qui était indépendante
déclaration du Président de la
République dans l'histoire Sarah limite
c'est la chambre de l'instruction de la
cour d'appel de Paris qui a jugé que le
l'auteur présumé enfin le suspect des
faits le mise en examen enfin qui avait
d'ailleurs reconnu l'effet donc on peut
dire l'auteur était avait une abolition
de son discernement au moment des faits
c'est une cause des responsabilité
pénale et aujourd'hui
donc aujourd'hui dans un état
psychiatrique au lieu d'être en prison
moi je trouve que c'est
remarquable au contraire que la justice
française parvienne à faire du de
l'opinion publique et de et des prises
de position des hommes politiques et des
médias sur cette lutte etc moi j'ai
quand même un peu de mal à donner du
crédit à ce que peut dire Madame borne
ou ce que peuvent dire les macronisme
quand ils prétendent lutter contre le
racisme et l'antisémitisme alors que ce
sont eux qui font tout pour avoir pour
seul adversaire l'extrême droite pour
cela l'adversaire politique tout en
saignant de lutter contre elle ils font
tout pour avoir des seconds tours contre
l'extrême droite ils sont incapables
d'assurer ce qu'on appelait avant le le
l'arc républicain je sais plus comment
on appelait ça le barrage républicain
contre le Front républicain merci contre
contre l'extrême droite et ça c'est
encore vérifier récemment dans des
législatives partielles donc je pense
qu'ils sont un peu hypocrites
franchement de la communication je crois
voilà je pense qu'il n'y croit pas
j'observe par ailleurs que ils vont
faire du testing sur la discriminels
discrimination à l'embauche c'est très
bien mais quand il fait récemment quand
il fait durant le précédent quinquennat
pour les jeunes de banlieue pour
favoriser leur insertion sur le marché
du travail ou dans les grandes écoles où
les universités ils n'ont rien fait
Nicolas Sarkozy avait fait des internats
d'excellence qu'on peut discuter
François Hollande avait fait les emplois
aidés qu'on peut discuter qu'est-ce qui
a été fait sous Macron pour ces jeunes
là rien il y a une reproduction sociale
en France comme jamais il y en a eu
auparavant donc leur déclaration moi
elle me font un peu penser en effet à
des postures hypocrites qui sont suivies
d'aucun effet et que vous êtes d'accord
moi je suis complètement d'accord avec
ce qu'il y en a dit je pense que dans ce
plan il y a des bonnes choses
c'est-à-dire mieux former les personnels
des agents publics
à la question enfin la prévention du
racisme de l'antisémitisme aider à
objectiver aussi ça avec ces trucs de
testing c'est important de libérer la
parole sur sur la réalité du racisme en
France c'est comme ça qu'on a fait avec
les violences sexistes et sexuelles avec
Mitou c'est quand on a libéré la parole
que la société a pu regarder ce gros
problème en face donc il y a des choses
qui sont positives mais j'ai envie de
dire que si on veut vraiment
dire le fléau du racisme en France qui
brise des vies qui tuent il suffit pas
d'organiser des visites mémorielles pour
dire qu'il y a 150 ans il y avait
l'esclavage c'est c'est très sympa c'est
très important mais c'est pas ça qui va
régler le problème du racisme en France
c'est comme le disait Charles Consigny
briser l'endogamie des sphères du
pouvoir politique du pouvoir économique
qui ne reflète pas du tout la diversité
de la société française et donc pour ça
il faut mettre le paquet sur la question
scolaire briser les ghettos scolaires
qui regroupent des ghettos urbains
aujourd'hui en France et qui sont un
obstacle à et qui qui favorise la
reproduction sociale il faudrait aussi
s'attaquer pardon ce que ce plan ne fait
pas au racisme dans la police aux délit
de faciès qui est objectivé par le
Défenseur des droits et par tout un tas
d'études aujourd'hui on refuse on refuse
d'imposer par exemple le système des
récépissés de contrôle d'identité mais
c'est insupportable de savoir que quand
vous êtes noir ou arabe
et ben vous avez je ne sais combien de
plus de chances de vous faire arrêter
par la police de vous faire contrôler
c'est des humiliations au quotidien et
ça ça est-ce que les autres c'est
insupportable ça c'est un supportable et
franchement ça n'est pas dans le plan et
ce qui n'est pas non plus dans le plan
c'est les le recours au statistiques
ethniques est-ce que ça vous paraît
normal est-ce que il y a un tabou qui
existe encore toujours en France là
dessus Rachel il y a un tabou mais en
même temps il y a des rapports qui qui
démontrent est-ce qu'on a véritablement
besoin de statistiques pour voir le réel
je sais pas enfin bon ça se discute si
quand le le ça se discute le truc c'est
qu'effectivement je suis entièrement
d'accord sur reprendre cette
problématique là à la base mais comme
vous l'évoquez c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
plusieurs périodes dans cette lutte
antiracisme notamment de cette
association que je citais tout à l'heure
SOS Racisme aujourd'hui c'est de
considérer aussi que le racisme n'a pas
de couleur de peau n'a pas de religion
malheureusement le racisme est partagé
peut-être partager par tous quel que
soit quel que soit nos origines et ses
une forme d'intolérance là et bien
effectivement c'est plus qu'un plan
qu'il faut mettre en place
au fond la réponse au racisme ces
firation c'est ça et la réponse elle a
pas été apportée ni par Macron ni parole
en ni par Sarkozy frères nation voilà et
ce sens-là cette définition
c'est quels sont ces barbares
Renan
de 1865 c'est le discours à la nation
c'est-à-dire les valeurs auxquelles on
adhère et se référant donne des valeurs
peut permettre en effet de faire reculer
c'est pas la seule possibilité
c'est l'adhésion des valeurs c'est
considéré que les valeurs sont
supérieures à l'été à des valeurs quand
vous faites contrôler de façon
est-ce que vous dénoncez à juste titre
ça n'est pas surnation bah oui ah
d'accord bon et remettre l'école
républicaine au centre depuis petit à
prendre à être à devenir des citoyens et
et participe à faire cette nation parce
que nous ne sommes pas un peuple
ethnique nous sommes pas un peuple
religieux nous sommes un peu politique
qui nous retrouvons
autours
ministériels
regardez la composition des des des
banques chics d'affaires regardez la
composition
des conseils regardez qui est à l'École
normale supérieure qui est à Sciences Po
qui est HEC qui est au collège de droit
d'Assas regardez regardez
ez et vous allez chercher là-dedans et
vous aurez bien du mal à trouver une
petite chose vous allez chercher des
gens qui sont nés en Seine-Saint-Denis
merci bon et vous ne les trouverez pas
voilà et je suis désolé de dire que
typiquement Macron on attendait quand
même un peu de lui après peut-être qu'il
était tellement flou que chacun a vu
midi à sa porte mais mais on attendait
un peu de lui qu'il fasse quelque chose
là-dessus on s'était dit bon la jeunesse
et cetera finalement rien de rien de
rien c'est ça le le la difficulté qu'on
a et tous ces plans tant qu'on règlera
pas ça ne serviront à rien mais tant
qu'on se parle
maintenant qu'on se bat pas il a le
droit
sur la question justement de la
méritocratie de l'école d'aller
s'arracher justement pour obtenir ces
boulots là alors évidemment avec la
justice d'accéder en fonction de ses
compétences au même droit et au même au
même travail ou même poste c'est ça le
sujet mais aujourd'hui il se passe des
choses aussi beaucoup plus complexes
vous avez parlé de 93 alors que là on a
parlé de couleur de peau et d'origine
plutôt ethnique au fond on va parler
d'un autre social dossier brûlant le
très brûlant sujet de l'immigration
parce que ce mercredi le gouvernement a
présenté un projet de loi pour expulser
davantage les étrangers et régulariser
certains travailleurs sans papier une
manière aussi pour Gérald Darmanin et
ben de faire du pied à la droite écouter
le
esprit constructif que l'on souhaite
porter ce texte qui est important pour
les Français et je veux le dire qu'il
fait des choses que aucun gouvernement
n'a fait auparavant et je veux dire à
mes amis LR je crois que il faut se
rendre compte que si nous expulsions pas
des étrangers délinquants c'est parce
qu'il y a eu des dispositions qui ont
été imaginées notamment par eux qui nous
empêchent de le faire et qu'on peut pas
faire à la fois
la critique que nous expulsons pas assez
et empêcher mis de l'Intérieur
d'expulser par la loi Charles queue les
mesures de gouvernement vous paraissent
intéressantes je vais juste peut-être
les citer avant de vous interroger vous
les connaissez déjà mais le gouvernement
propose d'expulser davantage les
étrangers qui représentent une menace
grave pour l'ordre public de réformer le
système d'asile pour expulser plus
efficacement ou encore de régulariser
certains travailleurs en leur attribuant
un titre de séjour valide un an dans les
métiers dit en tension
toute la question ce sera est-ce qu'on
le fait ou pas
personnellement je n'ai rien contre la
double peine qui avait été supprimée par
Sarkozy à l'époque à mon avis pour
plaire à une certaine gauche et pour et
dans un but politique la double peine
c'est si vous êtes condamné par une
juridiction pénale en France et que vous
êtes de nationalité étrangère on vous
expulse du territoire à l'issue de
l'accomplissement de votre peine ça me
paraît pas extravagant de demander aux
gens qui ne sont pas nationalité
française de ce comporter correctement
sur le territoire français et s'y
commettent un crime ou un délit qu'on
les raccompagne dans leur pays d'origine
c'est ça me paraît être une une comment
dire l'hospitalité elle doit aller dans
les deux sens donc ça ça je pense que ça
doit être possible cette histoire de
grave menaces sur l'ordre public etc je
ne sais pas trop ce que ça veut dire moi
ce que je pense simplement c'est que on
a à peu près un quart des détenus en
France qui sont de nationalité étrangère
c'est pas très politiquement correct
peut-être de le dire mais la France
n'est pas obligée de garder sur son
territoire des personnes de nationalité
étrangères qui commettent des crimes ou
des c'est le 29e texte sur les
migrations depuis 1980 est-ce que c'est
le bon Chloé celui-là alors là
de l'immigration mais parce que on a on
a pris le problème dans dans le problème
on a pris les choses déjà le sujet a été
passionné c'est-à-dire qu'on a perdu je
pense nous à gauche la bataille du récit
et puis la bataille des faits aussi
parce qu'on a été incapable de réussir
l'intégration je parlais des ghettos
scolaires tout à l'heure c'est quelque
chose de très problématique la bataille
du récit c'est quoi elle a été gagnée
par l'extrême droite sur l'immigration
l'immigration c'est ancré dans
l'inconscient des Français comme une
sorte de tragédie submersible donc je
pense qu'il faut ramener de la raison
dans tout ça et arrêter de rendre la vie
impossible à ceux qui veulent migrer sur
notre territoire parce que là c'est la
meilleure façon de ne pas réussir leur
intégration et il faut répéter et
contredire le récit de l'extrême droite
sur ce sujet l'immigration peut être une
grande chance pour notre pays ça vient
enrichir on a des besoins dans le marché
du travail regarder en Allemagne ce
qu'ils font ils s'apprête à ouvrir les
vannes de la migration et accueillir les
gens dans bonne condition parce que ils
ont des grandes tensions sur leur marché
du travail donc moi je dans cette loi il
y a notamment une disposition mais qui
est pas assez qui va pas assez loin mais
pour assouplir effectivement
l'immigration dans les médias
après il y a la question de l'exécution
des auqf les obligations de quitter le
territoire français on nous dit que
seuls 20% de ses au qtf sont
exécutés en tant que républicain on peut
se dire ah bah tiens on est scandalisé
par le fait que la loi ne soit pas
respectée sauf que je pense qu'il y a
derrière ça le fait que on fait des
occultés F à tour de bras et on le voit
souvent dans la presse ça revient des
gens qui sont frappés dans qtf alors que
ce sont des jeunes qui sont en
apprentissage en boulangerie ou dans tel
entreprise et qu'on devrait pas frapper
d'une occupé donc je pense qu'il faut
déjà il y a un problème il y a un trop
grand nombre il y a un trop grand nombre
de qtf par contre quand on décide il
faut qu'on s'accorde sur ce que quand on
décide il faut l'exécuter ça c'est clair
parce que sinon vous brisez
l'accepte enfin l'application de la loi
et vous briser la confiance etc donc je
pense que cette loi ne couvre pas ne
couvre pas tous ces tous ces sujets et
puis
renforce le petit le récit la petite
musique qui vient de l'extrême droite
qui sont assez allier fermeté et
humanité c'est possible de faire de en
même temps cette tradition la traduction
de ministres des gentils avec les
gentils les méchants
le bien que je pense cette formule qui
prend français pour des idiots non
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en macronie
c'est comment éviter que Marine Le Pen
devienne présidente de la République
offenser ça cette loi cette loi c'est
fait justement pour aller sur la route
éviter parce que finalement ça obsède
les gens à tort ou à raison
or la réponse c'est finalement une
réponse macroniste en même temps by
gentil avec les gentils méchant avec les
méchant ceux qui préoccupent les gens et
à mon avis les juristes doivent être
deux choses et ce qui est devenu
insupportable chance ces fameuses
obligations de quitter le territoire
français c'est devenu insupportable ça
c'est pas dans la loi que 20% 18% 15%
soit respecté c'est insupportable sur le
plan républicain car après tout les
États-Unis sont pas paysagiste et on
peut accueillir qui on veut sur son
territoire ça je je le pense
profondément deuxièmement le dévoiement
du droit d'asile c'est devenu n'importe
quoi le droit d'asile enfin là aussi je
parle sur ton contrôle cette haute et
cette grande noble cause qui est liée
finalement d'ident de la France pour
qu'on accueille etc a été totalement
dévoyé donc tout explose or la réponse
que fait le gouvernement français c'est
finalement un brouillard gentil avec les
gentils méchant avec moi donc
l'efficacité l'armantine Marine Le Pen
n'est pas du tout probante et donc on va
repartir sur une 30e loi depuis 1980 et
politique c'est ce qui nous dit mais qui
ne marche hélas marchera pas Rachel
c'est véritablement le marronnier 30e
proposition effectivement moi je partage
sur le droit d'asile notamment mais le
fait que l'immigration soit une richesse
pour notre pays c'est pas un scoop notre
pays c'est fondé sur l'immigration donc
tous autour de la table on est tous
autour de la table on est on est
d'origine bon mais éperdument français
et effectivement on arrive dans une
irrationalité à chaque fois de ce débat
c'est
comment vous l'expliquer
les rationalités oui parce qu'on est on
est parce qu'on n'est pas ce qu'on est
plus on arrive plus effectivement à
mettre la raison au centre à mettre le
réel les les chiffres sur la table à
mettre voilà les exactions et la manière
d'y répondre et effectivement le fait
que ce débat sur l'immigration qui est
un enjeu politique majeur qui doit être
partagé par l'ensemble de nos
représentants il a été déporté vers
l'extrême droite l'extrême droite on est
emparé et qu'on arrive plus à réfléchir
autour de ce sujet en tout cas les
oppositions réagi aux annonces du
gouvernement et sans grande surprise ça
sera sans aller écouter
ils vont recommencer
c'est la 32e loi en 20 ans
sans arrêt des lois et encore des lois
sont tellement
inutiles à part pour blesser et humilier
les mesures individuelles qui peuvent
être dans le bon sens sont pas au niveau
du problème qui est le nôtre en matière
de dérégulation totale d'une immigration
devenue anarchique qu'on ne maîtrise
l'accélération
et ça ne compense pas si vous voulez la
création d'une forme de campagne de
régularisation de clandestin qui est un
appel d'air je le crois à une
immigration clandestine d'ailleurs
nouvelle qui espèrera demain une autre
régularisation bon ce sera sans les
insoumis sans le rassemblement national
et puis les républicains disent bah non
votre appât cette loi ce projet de loi
immigration comment vous expliquer ça je
ne sais pas très honnêtement je sais pas
pourquoi il le voudront pas peut-être
qu'ils estiment que c'est une loi
inutile après moi je pense qu'il ne faut
pas faire d'angélisme quand même sur
l'immigration on sait que le climat les
phénomènes d'accroissement de population
dans beaucoup de pays en Afrique
notamment vont conduire à des vagues
migratoires
supplémentaires et qu'on pourra pas
forcément toutes les accueillir surtout
avec le système social qu'on a qui est
universel et qui et qui fait que que ça
ça nous coûte aussi de l'argent
d'accueillir de l'immigration même si ça
peut nous en rapporter par d'autres
aspects donc je je crois que c'est un
sujet qui est difficile personne n'a
envie de voir des policiers faire la
chasse aux étrangers etc mais c'est un
sujet qui me paraît pas pouvoir être
traité avec des bons sentiments on va
reparler des républicains se dirige-t-on
avec cette question se dirigeant vers
une meilleure protection de l'IVG en
France cette semaine le Sénat a donné
son feu vert à l'inscription du droit à
l'avortement dans la Constitution le
grand artisan de cette adoption c'est
lui regardez
chers collègues je vous propose
d'effacer totalement la proposition qui
nous vient de l'Assemblée nationale pour
écrire que la loi détermine les
conditions dans lesquelles s'exerce la
liberté de la femme de maître fin à sa
grossesse la loi veille pourra continuer
à évoluer vous savez que si elle avait
été cristallisée dans la Constitution
aucune évolution n'aurait été possible y
compris celle des dernières années cette
adoption par le Sénat c'est une victoire
pour le droit des femmes non mais c'est
une victoire c'est une avancée mais moi
ce qui me ce qui me révolte je vais le
dire comme ça c'est la réécriture du
Sénat de l'article qui avait été adopté
par l'Assemblée nationale l'Assemblée
nationale avait adopté un article qui
disait que la Constitution doit garantir
les galaxies au droit et l'effectivité
du droit à l'avortement pour toutes les
femmes beaucoup parce qu'on va voir la
rédaction effectivement du Sénat la loi
détermine les conditions dans lesquelles
s'exerce la liberté de la femme de
mettre fin à sa grossement qui a été
adopté la formulation du Sénat mais
pourquoi en fait
pourquoi pourquoi ces hommes blancs
vieux au Sénat vont réécrire ainsi
l'article adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale et préférée surtout une
formulation plus faible parce que quel
est l'intérêt de mettre et de garantir
le droit à l'avortement dans la
Constitution on voit que dans les
démocraties en Europe aux États-Unis
l'avortement est menacé et il est pas
toujours menacé de façon frontale comme
c'est le cas dans plusieurs États
américains qui ont carrément interdit
l'avortement mais dans des états par
exemple comme la Hongrie ou dans des
régions qui sont gouvernées par
l'extrême droite en Espagne on va non
pas interdire le droit à l'avortement
mais chercher à humilier et à
stigmatiser les femmes qui souhaitent
avorter en les obligeant à une
consultation psychologique en les
obligeant à écouter le cœur de leur
fœtus c'est le cas en Hongrie c'est le
cas aussi en Castilla et Leon en Espagne
et donc quand on met dans la
Constitution qu'on doit garantir
l'effectivité du droit à l'avortement on
protège les femmes contre ce type
d'atteinte insidieuses à leurs droits
reproductif bisexuelle et ça c'est
fondamental parce que demain ça ça peut
être ça peut être menacé par une
formulation
aujourd'hui avec cette formulation qui a
donc été réécrite par Philippe bar à
Chelles c'est comme important cette
avancée du Sénat sur cette question qui
pourra peut-être donner on va en parler
mais qui pourra peut-être déboucher sur
quelque chose ensuite au niveau
constitutionnel oui c'est important
alors c'est vrai que je reviendrai pas
sur les hommes blancs qui prennent la
parole mais parce que si on part de là
ça voudrait dire que finalement en
termes de racisme ou d'antisémitisme
j'aurais dû être la seule à prendre la
parole donc bon donc c'est bon mais sur
le fond
je repense à nos pères
ceux qui ont écrit la Déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme etc je
pense qu'ils se retrouve aujourd'hui
dans ou la déclaration de des droits de
l'homme et du citoyens qui se retrouvent
dans le dans le préambule de la
Constitution si on devait l'écrire
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on mettrait
cette liberté là
ses droits des ce droit des femmes là
dans la Constitution donc pour moi c'est
ça apparaît effectivement comme une
avancée c'est une avancée George Mac on
est dans le symbole mais les symboles
sont aussi importants
juridique je les connais pas bien la
constitutionnalisation oui protège mais
faut savoir que on est dans des
institutions qui peuvent être
dangereuses ce qui a été fait peut être
des faits je peux même au niveau concile
donc oui c'est une avancée et
effectivement les tentatives
révisionnistes sur l'avortement sur le
racisme elle reviendront et il faut être
d'une extrême vigilance par rapport à
ces tentatives de remettre en question
la liberté du corps des femmes
l'avortement et toutes ces conquêtes et
qu'elles sont insidieuses on le voit
bien et en effet en Hongrie en Pologne
etc et nul n'est à l'abri en France de
de de de choses qui peuvent être
catastrophiques là dessus sur cette
débat beaucoup de de rédaction de de
l'article mais protéger l'IVG dans la
Constitution à quoi ça sert une question
simple c'est plus difficile de modifier
la Constitution que de modifier la loi
et donc ça permet de faire en sorte que
si demain on a une majorité de députés
une majorité parlementaire même député
sénateurs d'ailleurs d'extrême droite et
qu'il se mette à soit faire quelques
quelques restrictions à l'IVG soi-même
imaginons l'interdire si ça me paraît
quand même en France un peu un peu
difficile à imaginer ils ne pourront pas
le faire tant que il ne pourra ils ne
pourront pas promulguer des lois qui
seront en contradiction avec avec la
Constitution
ils seront saturés par un Conseil
constitutionnel il faudrait qu'il
modifie la Constitution pour pour y
parvenir ce qui est techniquement plus
plus compliqué plus difficile moi je
trouve qu'on constitutionnalise beaucoup
de choses je suis pas toujours certain
de l'urgence à le faire là je peux
comprendre que ce qui s'est passé aux
États-Unis et ce qui se passe dans l'Est
de l'Europe
angoisse les les démocrates et les
progressistes et que donc on souhaite
faire ça pour se prémunir d'un éventuel
risque je suis pas sûr que on est on se
réagisse pas un peu voilà après pourquoi
pas j'aurais pas voté contre ces
propositions si j'avais été
parlementaire alors justement le groupe
LR au Sénat on en parlait à très
majoritairement voté contre l'amendement
de filibam et les choses pourraient être
un peu différentes à l'Assemblée
nationale pour les députés elle est
écoutée ce que vous êtes pour
l'inscription dans dans la constitution
du droit à l'avortement oui j'ai voté à
l'Assemblée nationale dans ce sens et si
j'étais sénateur je voterai également
dans ce sens je voterai l'amendement du
de Philippe Bas qui questeur du Sénat
mais qui a été président de la
commission des lois qui a introduit un
amendement qui me paraît dans sa
rédaction constitutionnelle
beaucoup plus pertinent parlant de
liberté de la femme à choisir sa
grossesse il y a quand même une
évolution des mentalités sur cette
question on voit Éric Ciotti on va
d'autres députés à l'air qui
effectivement donc maintenant oui il
faut constituer le constitutionnaliser
ce droit oui c'est certain que c'est
assez surprenant de voir comme ça un
député LR comme Éric Ciotti se prononcer
en faveur de l'inscription du droit de
la liberté pardon à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans la dans la
Constitution mais le
diable se cache dans les détails
l'intérêt de la formulation de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est-à-dire
garantir l'effectivité de l'accès aux
droits à l'avortement permet dans la
pratique de mettre en œuvre cette
effectivité qui aujourd'hui même sur le
territoire français n'est pas toujours
garanti parce que vous avez notamment ce
qu'on appelle la clause de conscience
que je trouve personnellement moi
très dommageable je suis désolé je
trouve que ça ne devrait pas exister des
médecins qui font valoir leur clause de
conscience ils doivent procéder à cette
opération je vois pas pourquoi on
continuerait à accepter ça parce que par
exemple en Italie vous avez 70% des
médecins qui la font valoir donc ça
c'est un obstacle concret à
l'effectivité du droit à l'IVG si vous
si vous habitez dans le fin fond du
territoire et que en fait vous avez pas
15000 médecins qui sont capables de
procéder à un IVG et que tout se font
valoir leur clause de confiance votre
garantie effective à ce droit là n'est
pas respecté donc voilà c'est à ça que
ça sert aussi cette formulation et cette
inscription le texte il va repartir à
l'Assemblée nationale donc on reparlera
bien sûr de ce sujet dans nos prochaines
émissions autre question faut-il taxer
les plus riches pour sauver la planète
c'est notre dernier thème si l'on une
étude du laboratoire sur les inégalités
mondiales publiées cette semaine les 10%
les plus riches sont responsables de la
moitié de la moitié des émissions de CO2
au niveau mondial écouter l'un des
auteurs de le rapport c'était il y a
quelques mois
classe populaire dans leur immense
majorité en France aujourd'hui c'est le
cas aussi dans les autres pays du monde
même si elle ne se disent pas écolo même
si elle ne se pense pas écolo elles sont
deux facto beaucoup plus écologiques que
les classes moyennes et que les classes
aisées il faut mettre à contribution
pour commencer ce qui peuvent faire la
transition et quand on n'a pas
d'alternative bah évidemment c'est
compliqué le deuxième point c'est que on
a besoin d'un système fiscal qui
fonctionne même indépendamment de la
question climat et là je pense qu'on a
besoin d'un système fiscal qui met à
contribution les plus aisées les 10% les
plus riches sont responsables de la
moitié des émissions de CO2 au niveau
mondial George Marc est-ce que ce
chiffre vous étonne
oui bonjour je sais pas comment il est
trouvé probablement qu'il est oui c'est
choquant et c'est foncé les
disproportions par classe sociale mais
aussi territorial qui sont frappantes
parce que faut-il taxer les bien sûr que
la solidarité elles doivent fonctionner
mais elles doivent fonctionner entre les
classes sociales mais aussi entre les
pays parce qu'en fait si demain la
France maintenue
pour la transition écologique elle est
toute seule à l'intérieur de l'Europe ou
à l'intérieur du monde ça ne marchera
pas donc les la solidarité je répondrai
pas au niveau de taxation elle est
valable pour les classes sociales pour
les individus et pour les pays si
Poutine ne règle pas son problème en
Sibérie avec la fonte des des glaces qui
va dégager des bactéries qui datent de
la préhistoire et qui vont etc si la
Chine calme pas si le l'Allemagne
n'arrête pas le charbon donc c'est aussi
bien des problèmes de classe sociale
c'est c'est très à la mode d'accélérer
mais aussi des disparités régionales et
nationales la taxe qui est proposée
c'est une taxe progressive sur les
richesses des 0, ce sont des plus aisés
dans le monde ça permettrait de générer
1100 milliards de dollars par an parfait
Charles moi je me méfie des mesures qui
vont consister à
contrôler les gens selon leur émission
de carbone je sens que c'est quelque
chose qui est évidemment démange les
gens de gauche parce qu'ils vont voir là
un bon moyen de punir les voisins qui
gagnent plus d'argent que moi je reste
sur ce sujet là très basiquement de
droite je pense que parfois quand votre
voisin gagne plus d'argent que vous
c'est qui travaille peut-être un peu
plus qui se lève un peu plus tôt donc il
faut pas taxer pour sauver la planète je
pense qu'on peut faire beaucoup de
choses pour sauver la planète mais je
crois que cette obsession de la taxe qui
qui anime beaucoup de gens et à mon avis
beaucoup par par jalousie je dis les
choses comme je les pense
n'est pas n'est pas féconde je crois
qu'on peut faire beaucoup d'autres
choses pour par exemple la Chine que
George Marc a cité fait énormément de
choses en réalité contrairement à l'idée
qu'on s'en fait pour la transition
énergétique dans les panneaux solaires
dans beaucoup de sujets comme ça en plus
à très grande échelle et donc je crois
qu'on peut on peut inventer beaucoup de
choses sans aller vers un système où on
va se mettre à regarder finalement
combien de voitures chacun possède
combien de fois il prend l'avion par an
à quoi combien de degrés chauffent son
appartement moi j'ai pas très envie de
rentrer dans ce dans ce système là c'est
de l'écologie punitive c'est ce que
j'entends à ma gauche non moi je crois
que ce que montre ce rapport c'est que
l'écologie est un socialisme en réalité
qu'on ne pourra pas
que c'est très bien qu'on ne pourra pas
respecter les limites planétaires sans
réduire drastiquement les inégalités
sans ramener les riches sur terre et je
parle des 1% les plus riches pas de son
voisin sans mettre en place une
gouvernance démocratique des biens
communs l'eau l'air la terre et donc les
propositions de formules se rapportent
pour se faire me semble me semble
bienvenu c'est à dire de taxation
notamment sur le patrimoine des plus
riches la mise la mise à contribution de
l'impôt mondial sur les sociétés qui a
été adoptée dans le cadre de l'OCDE pour
abonder un fond climat on pourrait aussi
penser à une tarification progressive de
l'énergie de l'eau puisque le fait que
les les plus riches et une empreinte
carbone délirante et
éminemment plus supérieur au plus
pauvres c'est aussi le fait qu'il
consomme il consomme énormément d'eau
énormément d'énergie pour
arroser leur
remplir leur piscine ou voyager en jet
privé etc donc il faut se mettre à mieux
taxer ses émissions ses émissions
carbone mais je pense que là avec ce
rapport on a la démonstration que
l'écologie on savait que ça ça aurait
pas été démocratique déjà et soutenable
de faire reposer l'effort sur les plus
pauvres mais on sait désormais que c'est
aussi impossible donc je crois que c'est
très utile l'écologie doit être radicale
c'est ce que nous dit cloué une certaine
manière Rachel en tout cas de prendre la
mesure et la responsabilité la
responsabilité au niveau international
effectivement d'avoir de changer
complètement de prisme pour qu'il y ait
effectivement cette solidarité parce que
lorsqu'on regarde ce rapport les
inégalités effectivement elles se
situent au sein des États même et alors
aux États-Unis le colossal la disparité
est colossale lorsqu'on regarde les
chiffres et puis entre les États c'est
vrai que la question du dérèglement
climatique aujourd'hui alors que nous en
Occident on consomme énormément l'impact
est extrêmement fort notamment en
Afrique moi j'ai des tentes aujourd'hui
qui vivent s'il n'y a pas de canicule
c'est-à-dire qu'elles vivent constamment
à 40 degrés parce qu'elles sont proches
du Sahel et donc il y a plus d'eau voilà
l'agriculture c'est catastrophique on
parlait de l'immigration tout à l'heure
mais l'immigration climatique elle se
fait parce que on ne peut pas vivre
là-bas parce que les conditions c'est
l'enfer sur terre donc effectivement
d'avoir
soit des entreprises alors Apple par
exemple que j'ai analysé les chiffres
d'Apple Apple consomment à un bilan
carbone qui équivaut par an à celui de
Paris et aujourd'hui il fait des petites
mesurettes pour compenser en fait pour
compenser la restauration des forêts
c'est une forme de gringochine moi je
suis pour une responsabilité des
personnes qui qui ont un impact beaucoup
plus fort que les plus pauvres qui ont
un impact et qui subissent surtout la
question du dérèglement et des
pollutions et autres très rapidement ça
veut dire changer de modèle de société
georges-barc si je le comprends si j'ai
bien compris
dans la créativité il s'agit pas de
faire du stalinisme et du flickael
généralisé
je suis assez d'accord avec la tentation
de fliquer les gens etc de façon
démocratique je pense que c'est un test
un énième test de la capacité de la
puissance publique à défendre une
conception universaliste de
l'émancipation dans
on a supprimé les braseros sur les
terrasses en France vous savez les
fumeurs sont obligés maintenant de se
peler direction plus le droit de fumer à
l'intérieur ils peuvent même plus fumer
au chaud on a supprimé évidemment ça ne
sert à rien sur le plan climatique c'est
brasero c'est infinités images on l'a
fait pour le symbole on l'a fait changer
quelques éléments on le fait pour le
plaisir d'emmerder son prochain et moi
je me méfie de cette tentation là et au
nom de l'écologie vous allez voir qu'on
va devoir tout accepter comme chaque
semaine on termine l'émission par un top
flop une question simple à chacun
d'entre vous quel personnalité a marqué
l'actualité en bien ou en mal on va
commencer avec vous George Marc c'est un
TOP un peu particulier cette semaine oui
c'est la disparition de Philippe Tesson
qui a été
qui a probablement
animé était présent sur cette antenne et
qui est très proche de du producteur
Alexandra miel qui a été mon premier
patron moi je me souviens que à il y
avait encore c'était au XXe siècle une
presse écrite le quotidienne Paris plus
encore que Libération brille tous ses
feux c'est un journal paradoxal
totalement anarexanar de gauche des
anneards de droite et c'était moi le
journal où je rêvais de d'entrer et que
j'étais accueilli dans ce journal
totalement foutraque et créatif avec
beaucoup de bonheur et que ce patron là
était
bienveillant plus fou que nous
très et qu'il a donné sa chance à plein
plein plein de journalistes de talent
etc vous n'imaginez pas donc c'est un
homme de liberté de créativité un
amoureux du théâtre un amoureux de la
littérature enfin c'était l'époque
presque balsacienne ou il y avait de la
presse écrite et et comme le disait
Geneviève d'orman il avait toujours une
lumière allumée c'était un journal la
nuit où on pouvait s'arrêter pour les
insomnies niaque et le Quotidien de
Paris c'était ça Charles vous vouliez
aussi parler dans votre top de Philippe
Tesson oui moi aussi j'ai la chance de
le connaître un peu et notamment j'avais
un enfin je l'ai croisé plusieurs fois
grâce au magazine Le Point et je l'ai
connu aussi dans ma campagne législative
là toute récente puisque Philippe Tesson
habitait à Chatou où j'étais candidat et
je me souviens qui nous avait reçu très
gentiment pendant un assez long moment
avec mes jeunes militants et tout homme
de 80 14 ans qu'il était il les avait
complètement charmé et complètement
bluffé par son par son intelligence par
son humour voilà donc c'était vraiment
un homme merveilleux Philippe Tesson
Rachel votre top et votre flop de la
semaine alors mon top
Amélie ou des accastera parce que j'ai
adoré oui ministre des Sports parce que
j'ai adoré comment elle a répondu
notamment au président de la Fédération
Française de Football le Great voilà
exactement et mon flop ce serait les
personnes d'amendements à l'Assemblée
nationale voilà par rapport à cette
proposition de retraite j'aurais aimé
d'avoir un débat sur le fond avec des
expertises et que les lois puissent se
construire et on leur a peut-être la
semaine prochaine Chloé votre top et
votre flop moi mon top c'est le texte
qui a été adopté
jeudi par le Parlement européen pour
reconnaître la présomption de salariés
pour les travailleurs des plateformes
donc les gens qui livrent des repas à
vélo notamment ces 4 millions de
travailleurs qui qui seraient
potentiellement salariés à travers
l'Europe et qui sont aujourd'hui dans un
faux statut d'indépendant enfin bref
qu'il est précarisé et votre flop mon
flop ce sera très rapide ce sera
l'interview de Elizabeth borne de jeudi
soir qui n'aura pas contribué à
améliorer le débat et la situation merci
beaucoup merci à tous les cas c'est la
fin de cette émission merci à vous
derrière votre écran me dit dans
l'oreillette que vous êtes de plus en
plus nombreux à nous suivre alors un
grand merci à vous continuez vous pouvez
aussi nous retrouver en replay et en
podcast on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine même jour
et même endroit
[Musique]